I'll throw a curveball at you in
hopefully it isn't a deal breaker but
I practice
celibacy
staying celibate oh
for two and a half months right now wow
okay
I do like I do spurts of like four
months six and then I'll release
this freaking hot ass guy
I don't know why you would waste time
and not having sex the reason why I
practice celibacy is
us men we feel
Invincible when we keep it in I've
always heard about this but once I
experienced it
I kind of understand the Gandhi's and
the Buddhas the monks of how they just
Channel all their energy and travel
Dimensions but naturally just by keeping
it in
I find so much joy stimulating a woman
mentally a physical thing anyone can do
that but once I just get into the
just Explore her mind and I get a sense
of how she's feeling it for me that's
better than sex all right talk is that
like breaking rules
you are going to get me in trouble here
holy cow I'm behaving sometimes I do
oh my God sometimes okay to break on a
little too
my Sexual Energy is through the roof and
I've learned to
put a tight hole caller on that bad boy
but
she woke something up inside of meat
it's been sleeping for a while I'm gonna
get me into some trouble here
ready to get out of here ready
yeah such strong arms you have wow
stop raining
it's beautiful out here
I had a great time
you're telling me
now I'm a little bummed that the night
ended so soon
well maybe he doesn't have to
foreign